[Música]
como qualquer momento o vazamento de
competitivo na história vivemos
simultaneamente a maior o tupi amnh
distopia christine lagarde em davos em
2018 abriu seu discurso com uma
afirmação feita mente bombástica
nós não estamos a vigiar o futuro dos
jovens mas sim a destruiu esta afirmação
praia - passou despercebida e passou
despercebida aos decisores políticos
passou despercebida à comunicação social
e passou despercebida aos prejuízos
econômicos
de fato os números são assustadores o
relatório de do fmi foi apresentado na
sequência dessa afirmação em indica que
durante o período de ajustamento à
pobreza dos jovens duplicou
enquanto ao contrário daquilo que eu
pensava e possivelmente muitos de vocês
pensavam também a pobreza das pessoas
com mais de 65 anos reduziu para metade
isto obviamente significa que dentro da
europa
nós temos um nível de pobreza estável
mas com um aumento para o dobro daquilo
que é pobreza dos jovens entre os 15 e
os 26 anos e uma redução para metade das
pessoas da pobreza relacionada com as
pessoas maravilhosas que lagarto usa um
poema do lance estranho dia para fazer
no fundo para construir aquela afirmação
de um poema chamas o que fazer ao som de
aso será um sonho aviado será como uma
uva que filha é ao sol quente
será como um caramelo que cristaliza e
adoça será talvez como um pesado fardo
ou fraca explosivos
a verdade é que nem explodiu e fez um
siena e um silêncio sepulcral
estes dados provavelmente iam ter
rejeitado todos porque todos nós ou
porque temos filhos ou porque somos
filhos que fizemos coisas a idéia do que
tu especial
tu vais conseguir ser aquilo que
quisermos e realmente o relatório afirma
é que vivemos e os nossos jovens os viva
em tudo carregado de incertezas o mtur
cágados emprego eo futuro cagaço
competição razão 50% dos jovens usos na
europa trabalham num formato de emprego
dito não tradicional
o saque eo emprego ao longo da vida
todos o com muitos de nós principalmente
aquelas que são da minha geração das
gerações que nos habituamos uso não é
exatamento paradigma deus 50% dos jovens
trabalham e mantém em situação de
pobreza em 50% dos jovens têm empregos
não tarda não standard e varjão webber
serbis e realmente os carros autônomos
podem ser uma coisa é absolutamente
fantástico que ninguém me encontraria
que verdadeiramente o número de
acidentes que podem evitar é incrível
nós temos que também pensar que o verso
caminho mistas
motoristas de táxi o que nós vamos fazer
com estas pessoas e 50 pacientes é
extremamente relevante em portugal 50
por cento das pessoas são impacto times
involuntários e tanto está empolgado em
todos os países em que o turismo tem um
impacto muito significativo
claro que tem uma dimensão importante e
portanto verdadeiramente as instituições
da segurança social às instituições
políticas
até os próprios sindicatos não se
preparar
eram para mitigar esta situação e fui
dando andamento o que acontece em
portugal e na europa é que nós temos uma
franja muito significativa de jovens
estão leves futuramente abandonados mas
espera os resultados verdadeiramente
podem ser ainda mais catastróficos e
aqui o que assistimos com o oferecimento
da robótica e com o crescimento entre 10
ficial realmente não traz resultados
nada positivo e este cenário já fica
trófico o primeiro relatório foi
publicado sobre o comunika tecnologia
iria impactar no mercado do trabalho
falava num número absolutamente incrível
47% dos trabalhos iriam ser impactadas
pela tecnologia
infelizmente os dados têm vindo a
crescer e os vários estudos feitos com
as consultoras faz futebol se ele tem um
número menor de perda do trabalho nos
razão nunca deixem os dois dígitos
acrescentar este se na a cenário
apocalíptico mais desde o santos
desemprego certamente constituirá um
problema sem dúvida muito significativo
agora verdadeiramente nós não podemos
continuar nestas de economias e entre 15
são tecnofink ricos e que acham que
verdadeiramente a tecnologia robótica
inteligência artificial vão resolver
todos os nossos problemas ou aqui os
fundamentos são tecnofóbicos o caminho
na lógica dos lojistas da primeira
revolução industrial tanto destruíram os
teares e realmente em situações em que o
perdas de emprego que gera uma posição
muito agressiva e previdência precisam
também não ser e provavelmente com
certeza temos que voltar ao nosso velho
stops e pensar que realmente esses
extremos não observem e nós temos que
encontrar uma posição em que
verdadeiramente a tecnologia só uma
oportunidade mas que verdadeiramente
seja uma oportunidade para voltar a pôr
o ser
ano para voltar a pôr a pessoa no centro
das preocupações mas o relógio digital
já roda furiosamente e muitas das
pessoas dizem mas tratamentos outras
soluções industriais ou será que
conseguiu seus e oriente receberá a
prenda da velocidade com que as coisas
estão a acontecer nós teremos tempo a
ser resilientes
teremos que ter não há outra forma a
responder esta questão
quer dizer neste momento tudo tem que
tudo pode ser a popularidade nós também
teremos que ser a prioridade e não há
dúvida nenhuma que vivemos numa europa
começo
vivemos numa europa com medo do turismo
vivemos na europa com medo da imigração
vivemos como europa com medo da
tecnologia mas neste momento o
treinamento não os pode paralisar este
medo e no fundo teremos que pensar
novamente a utopia de thomas morus do
bolso sociedade e da sociedade boa
realmente todos nós e que dão nos
empenharmos em ovar é que o que não pode
acontecer que é destruir os sonhos das
gerações futuras
mas vamos pensar com o sonho da geração
futura pensar que os custos do trabalho
é pensar a própria sobrevivência do ser
humano na terra e portanto não podemos
olhar para a tecnologia e sim e pensar
que a tecnologia ou pensar na tecnologia
através do trinitino tecnológico é
tecnologia por si não se desenvolve
quem desenvolve a tecnologia ser humano
enquanto ser humano enquanto a venda
ativa e responsável tem que ter a
coragem de viver verdadeiramente aquilo
que interessa ao ser humano viver ser
desenvolvido e que o que não interessa
ao ser humano e por isso não deve ser
desenvolvido e também esta situação que
nós não podemos deixar no fundo de
pensar e cada um de nossos empinar
obviamente que isto terá que passar por
reformas legislativas com formas de
censura
ação social a forma da própria forma
como as empresas olham posse os
trabalhadores a formas possivelmente
naquilo que são os valores que não
dependem só do nosso que dependem de um
conjunto de pessoas
mas francamente no fundo para para uma
com concelho como a uva do landsbanki e
ucs senhor ao sol
eu penso e pensar que realmente nada
mais do que transformar em todos um
caminho em advogados e embaixadores
desta causa
francamente é uma causa que cria uma
circunstância e henrique que nos obriga
a pensar a pensar não só o mundo mas que
pensar como é que nós enquanto cidadãos
enquanto país enquanto filhos nos cremes
santo visionar neste mundo preferiu
verdadeiramente essa seja mais uma no
site
no fundo nós temos que aprender a
desenhar uma nova antropologia ou
colocar o homem no saí de uma tecnologia
digital e como é que nós vamos fazer
isso para realmente garantir que o homem
consegue com descaso continua na posição
central no momento não têm respostas
definitivas
tem alguma vida e elas têm algumas
questões mas verdadeiramente não posso
dizer que exista uma uma média que pio
envolver as duas questões
estas questões claramente um dos locais
que é privilegiado para trabalhar estas
instituições circunstâncias é questão de
educação
ou seja cada vez mais nós enquanto
educadores 50 pais enquanto cidadãos
enquanto pessoas empregadas temos que
perceber que a educação não é o uso
compatível com criar competências para o
mercado de trabalho o que educa ção se
devem empenhar e cria competências para
viva ensinar as pessoas a fazer as suas
ser cidadãos ativos responsáveis
empáticos cidadãos que foi
verdadeiramente
ocupam com aquilo que é a dimensão não
só sua mas também do próprio e portanto
quando falamos de educação falamos
obviamente de e porque o mercado de
trabalho e varjão
hoje sabemos que em 2025 30% das pessoas
que estão no mercado de trabalho são mil
e menos pessoas com perfis completamente
diferentes daqueles que o que nós
conhecemos a deus suas que sabemos que
em 2025 20 por cento dos empregos vão
ser empregos que não existem hoje é que
nós continuamos empilhar nos ensinar e
formar as competências técnicas
nós temos mais é reformular esta ideia e
e eu estava eu ia dizer em voz alta mas
vou dizer idiota do soft skills e
perceber que realmente aquilo que a
educação do futuro traga passar pela
criatividade e pela resolução de
problemas tem ensinar as pessoas a ser
mais simpáticas a serem mais solidárias
a trabalhar em grupo
no fundo é criarmos uma sociedade mais
centrada nas em si e mais importante
ainda na sua a situação com os outros
tratamentos temos que mudar o foco e
portanto temos de deixar tempo tem que
deixar de ser entre internet das coisas
pra ser a internet as pessoas têm que
deixar de ser as tecnologias
inteligentes para sublinharmos que as
pessoas
essa sim é que é incerta e por gente e
tem que ser inteligentes no design do
mundo melhor e mais responsável e
escutando lewis quero e conversa dores e
o pergunto também joão razão fluem não
sanz os top gun fome wang anyi one
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]